Bob it was you who discovered this book
and and brought it to - Marty what was
it about it that got you excited well we
were working on another project Marty
and I wanted to do something for a while
we'd been years had gone by and and so
then we finally got a project and Jane
had gotten it and however we were at a
certain point of developing and marty
was starting to show me oh yeah French
Jean got back yeah films from the early
50s and France said yeah and and
style-wise you were trying to hire him
and I said well I got to read this book
that I spoke to Eric Roth a couple years
ago when it came out I heard coal I
heard you paint houses and so I said let
me read that for research and then I I
read it and then I immediately called
Marty after I read it and said you gotta
look at this and that's how it started
yeah I mean what when we talked about
when you mentioned like it's we were
trying to get a film together to do the
last picture we did together really was
casino in 1995 so over the years we've
been slipping and sliding you know
trying to find our way and see if you
went this way I went that way and maybe
we meet in the middle somehow and
eventually we realized what we got to do
this yeah Jane there was a long road
between these guys seeing a connection
and you guys actually getting a chance
to make the movie that it took time to
get the financing together can you talk
a little bit about what happened in that
time well first of all it's an honor and
a privilege to be able to be part of a
team that got them back together since
casino but what they don't mention in
this conversation about finding this
book is that we were on a call with Brad
gray in 2007 to greenlight
franki machine and it was at that moment
that they said okay there's this other
book and maybe we could combine the two
movies here paint houses and franki
machine and Brad gray then said okay so
you're turning a go
movie into a development deal at which
point what you heard all these and so
then two years past we got Steve
Zaillian involved with it Marty worked
with Steve Zaillian that script came to
fruition 2009 and then it was a very
long road and journey to getting getting
the financing until Netflix there was no
real financing I think right we couldn't
get the fine we could not get the
financing from 2009 until till why shoot
six 2006 2016 so it was a very long a
very long journey and lots of ins and
outs which makes its own movie our
remarkably you and Marty had never done
a film together what questions did you
have about stepping onto your first
Martin Scorsese set will he like me I've
always liked you he'll come on no I
didn't I didn't feel that way I felt
well I liked him no we like each other
we always have we known each other
how many men 14 at you first in 1970 oh
my with Francis Coppola since yeah
introduced ances Coppola said that I
want you to meet this great young
director and I thought why why said he's
the great dis and I met him and I when I
first saw him remember that it was the
play was called rats it was oh no I
thought I'm is really so no first that
that first night he introduced me to you
as before I did mean streets oh is 1970
he was telling my mother about
say he wants to put you in the godfather
up they didn't want you in because you
hadn't done a movie oh you know my life
oh yes Wow
but yeah I don't remember the rats thing
hey I'm sorry about that money tomorrow
would you directed it I directed I know
and I was just talking you know being
the actor director anyway it was great
me but it was so great knowing him and
so great to work with him I love him I
love what he does his whole career of
course and then to be working with him
is amazing it was amazing I like to say
this because it's very clear working
with Marty Scorsese's like if you're a
tightrope walker and you're like up
there 200 feet walking the wire you know
with Marty you got a net so you can't
fall really if you fall you'll be
alright so you take chances and I think
the chances that's one of them you know
that's one of the great signs of the
greatest directors is you feel you are
taking care of as an actor a big thing
because then you can go out on a limb
and also you can do other things and
then me the director just says corrects
you in a way and you have this this
overseer which helps a great deal it
just organizes you and at the same time
gives you freedom it's a great thing and
working with Bob is pretty good yeah but
we're old-timers together we've done it
together we've worked together so I
think I said enough Emma there's 160
locations in this movie 200 characters
background characters many time periods
at one point your guys are pushing
taxicabs into the river so what in this
vast logistically complicated script
gave you the biggest headache
oh boy this guy this guy right here
Rodrigo no I think just what you said
just the logistical complexities of
putting the production together much
like al says walking Marty's sort of his
safety net I feel like I'm sort of a bit
of a safety net for the production and
that's a huge sort of cross to bear
with these three and and everybody else
so that that's that was really you know
the whole production was just
logistically very very complex and
complicated and yeah you know all of it
that scene in particular which you've
now put back into my head that night was
like one for the one for the books I
mean with this that one er that you had
to navigate oh that was below zero Oh
God yeah having to coordinate that that
I mean where were you I have somewhere
Red Hook Brooklyn Wow
you know inviting named Red Hook it's
it's it's what do they call it not
gentrified but it's off the river
I guess the East River ma'am is it cold
yeah always go there that a lot of good
locations there because there's old
buildings abandoned nice Rodrigo you're
working with new tools on this film most
notably the tools that enabled you to do
enable the the d aging seems to be shot
can you can you talk a little bit about
the complexity of that and how that
impacted the way you worked indeed we
had to devise the this way of shooting
that each camera had two other cameras
attached to the main angle the main
camera to to get the information for
visual effects of depth so that they
could create the the visual effects for
the de-aging so the whole notion was
that we couldn't have tracking marks or
any sort of things of that sort that
traditionally to to do CGI effects you
would need you know all these points in
the faces and lastik balls in the face
and
things like all sorts of stuff and so
Pablo helman from ILM devised this rig
where you would use three cameras for
every angle so that meant we shot a lot
of the dialogue scenes with two angles
simultaneously so then that became six
cameras and then we had some scenes
where we shot with three angles
simultaneously had been nine cameras
with nine camera crews so that was a
challenge but I think for me the main
thing was designing a visual concept for
the movie that would span all these
decades and differentiate visually each
naked so that was a big part of our prep
and design how do you think this movie
is shaped by the fact that you made it
in your 70s
well I that feels right you know I mean
the whole thing is the whole story
reflects how we are getting older and
everything and it feels right and Marty
doing it the way he did it taking his
time and you know that's that's what I'm
happy about because it's a movie that
we're you know we're getting closer to
that to that time if you will and I said
as a matter of being it's like a
blessing to be able to have been able to
make the picture because we were able to
sit and funny way talk use the words
reflective or contemplative it sounds
like it's boring and that's what I said
how do you make it reflective and still
keep the interest of the audience you
know of the viewer in a way and that's
through the character Frank you know and
I used that as a guide what he was doing
but there was a great deal of you know
reflection and quiet actually and wasn't
much discussion on set we work you know
we go ahead and do it you know that was
it a lot of discussions in our
rehearsals which were more more
discussions rather than reading dialogue
but
but no it gave us the opportunity in
this point in our lives all of us to I
don't try to think about what the hell
we've done who we are and how it sums up
if it does it all you know it's amazing
to have been able to have the experience
do you think you could have made this in
your 40s or 50s no no no no no and no I
still had the other stuff in me it but
we were gonna do like was from Mean
Streets to Goodfellas to casino right so
each one had a different level about
that millyar in a way and casino was
that's why was the last time we work
together and that just like an explosion
you know you know it was 25 years ago
and some what happens in 25 years well I
thank you all very much for being here
thank you for being here